MANDY WAITE: I want to develop
a RESTful web service using
Google App Engine that's
consumed by my web application
[? management in a ?]
different domain.
How do I restrict the calls only
to my web application?
What are the best practices?
FRED SAUER: OK.
So this is a question of cross
domain, or what standards like
to refer to, cross
origin requests.
So if you look on the W3C
webpages, you'll find
something called CORS, C-O-R-S,
and it stands for
Cross Origin Request Source.
I forget the abbreviation,
I use it too much.
MANDY WAITE: It's called
CORS, isn't it?
FRED SAUER: Cross Origin
Requests Sharing, I believe,
is what the actual
abbreviation is.
And basically, this is a
mechanism whereby servers and
browsers agree on how to
communicate the domain of the
website that is making the
request to the server, and for
the server to either grant
access to that
content or forbid it.
And what you do is when you set
up simple resources, like
even images in an image tag, or
when you make an XML HTTP
request, you can specify
that that request is a
cross origin request.
So it's headed for a domain
other than the one that the
website's running on.
So maybe your website's on
migrateapp.com, and the back
end service that you're
connecting to in App Engine is
actually on
migratebackendservice.com.
And you can do that, but you
have to set this extra flag in
your HTML, in your JavaScript to
make cross origin request.
And then on the server for a
get request, there'll be an
extra HTTP header coming in,
that's the origin header.
And this is an indication to the
server that this request
came from another origin.
And right then you can make the
decision in your request
handler whether or not you want
to allow that request.
And you do that by sending
another response back, which
is the access control cross
origin allow, and you can
specify the domains
that are allowed.
If you make a post request or
a put request, then the
browser will do something even
smarter than that, it will
send what's called a pre-flag
request, and will send a
request in advance and get
permission before it actually
does the submission.
So the short answer to this
question is there are existing
standards to do this, it's
very easy to do.
Just look up or CORS,
C-O-R-S, and
implement the details there.
You can do that in your request
handler and your HTML
app, and you should
be good to go.